how's it going everybody so I've got a
lot of personal DMS with questions about
the James gun incident that happened the
past few days I wasn't going to do a
video on this because I didn't want my
personal opinion out there on the matter
but a lot of you have been asking me
what exactly happened why he got fired
because all you heard is that he got
fired and what it means for the future
of the guardians of the galaxy 3 and the
MCU so in this video I'll simply explain
the events that took place over the past
weekend why James gun was fired and what
it could possibly mean for the future of
the guardians of the galaxy and MCU in a
nutshell James gun was fired for some
tweets that he made back in 2010 that
concern rape and pedophilia recently
they've been brought back to the surface
and Disney has made the executive
decision to fire him from guardians of
the galaxy 3 here's what Disney had to
say about the situation the offensive
attitudes and statements discovered on
James's Twitter feed are indefensible
and inconsistent with our Studios values
and we have severed our business
relationship with him the interesting
thing is that James already had
apologized for these tweets back in 2012
when Disney had hired him to direct the
first guardians of the galaxy movie so
was Disney ok with this back in 2012 and
now that it's been brought back into the
light again and people are making a big
deal about it they're not okay with it
that's a question that will most likely
never have an answer to but of course
James Gunn has come out and apologized
for these tweets again he also issued a
final statement regarding the matter
when he closed his Twitter account with
his final tweet saying many people who
have followed my career know when I
started I viewed myself as a provocateur
making movies and telling jokes that
were outrageous and taboo as I have
discussed publicly many times as I've
developed as a person so has my work and
my humor he also issued this official
apology to the public my words of nearly
a decade ago were at the time totally
failed and unfortunate efforts to be
provocative I have regretted them for
many years since not just because they
were stupid not at all funny wildly
insensitive and certainly not
provocative like I had hoped but also
because they don't reflect the person I
am today or have been for some time
regardless of how much time has passed
I understand and accept the business
decision taken today even these many
years later I take full responsibility
for the way I conducted myself then all
I can do now be on offering my sincere
and heartfelt regret is to be the best
human being I can be accepting
understanding committed to equality and
far more thoughtful about my public
statements and my obligations to our
public discourse to everyone inside of
my industry and beyond I again offer my
deepest apologies love to all so what
does this mean for James Gunn and
guardians of the galaxy 3 well there's
already a petition going around for
James Gunn to be rehired to direct a
movie the petition already has over
200,000 signatures with the goal of
getting 300,000 but will this even be
enough James Gunn was going to play a
huge role in the cosmic expansion of the
MCU exploring characters like Adam
warlock the Eternals and characters that
we have not seen yet so James Gunn is
certainly very very valuable to Disney
and the MCU but it does not seem like
Disney's going to be very forgiving on
this the Guardians cast is certainly all
shook up and very heartbroken some
members have stepped up and started to
defend James Gunn saying that he's a
very genuine and great guy while some
have taken to Twitter to express their
heartbreak Zoe Saldana said it's been a
challenging weekend I'm not gonna lie
I'm pausing myself to take everything in
before I speak out of turn I just want
everyone to know I love all members of
my guardians of the galaxy family always
will Chris Pratt took to Twitter quoting
a Bible verse understand this my
brothers and sisters let every person be
quick to listen slow to speak slow to
anger James 1:19 and Karen Gillan also
spoke up saying love to every single
member of my guardians of the galaxy
family just to clarify I'll speak more
on this later but just wanted to make
sure that was out there love to you all
so the cast and the fans are all
certainly very devastated and
heartbroken but will this be enough for
Disney to change their minds and if they
don't change their minds and James Gunn
is out for good what will happen to
guardians of the galaxy 3 and the MCU I
think there are two different routes
that they could take to keep the MCU as
great as it is now and to keep moving
forward in the right direction I think
one of the routes that they could take
is Josh Whedon who is a part of big
things like agents of shield the first
Avengers movie in Avengers age of Ultron
and then of course the Russo brothers
who directed Avengers infinity war and
Avengers 4 we would obviously all love
for James Gunn to return but if he
doesn't I would feel the most
comfortable if the future of the MCU was
in the hands of the reso brothers and
Josh Whedon who do you all think would
be best to take over guardians of the
galaxy and help with the expansion of
the MCU let me know your thoughts in the
comments below hit the like button and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
so you can stay up to date on all things
Marvel DC and superhero thank you all so
much for watching woof woof
[Music]
you
[Music]